what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
clip from the fit and fresh
or fresh and fit podcast called high
value man
man roasts woman before i start do not
forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe
please um okay so let's see
got this
[Music]
well i think i bring feminine
inspiration to the table
like kelly rollins say i'm gonna be your
motivation
when you come home i'm gonna be in
lingerie i'm gonna keep it nice and
fresh and waxed for you i'm gonna cook
your food
you just gotta bring home the baby
that's good i don't ask for a lot
okay i mean okay okay hold on see i
gotta see you i got you
right god i did you guys you're on that
road
interesting yeah that's crazy that's
what men want
i want to know right
what do you look for in a woman so you
heard all these answers right what do
you look for
i mean yeah like of course most of them
is going to stand on they pretty they go
[ __ ] you and all that come home i don't
give a [ __ ] about none of that
[ __ ] man like we get that dime a dozen
like a [ __ ] got bread [ __ ]
i'm sick since 230 i'm smooth i even
without the money i had every woman i
ever wanted so
like just because you're gonna be at my
home when i come there cooking i don't
need that [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
i never needed it and i'm saying i need
a girl that's gonna understand what i go
through
who's gonna keep a [ __ ] on top
of his toes that's gonna push him and
motivate him
you know i mean that's also gonna come
with some ideas you know i mean
give me creative criticism on my grind
you know what i mean also add add
to the to the table you know i mean not
just trying to grab some food every time
it's filled up you know what i mean you
got to bring something to this table
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] is over with after a
certain time like we could i could [ __ ]
any [ __ ] i ever wanted in my life i
always have that's not appealing to me
no more
you know what i mean once you get money
and once she was already having that
you got to bring more your energy got to
be right your mind got to be right
that body don't he's like saying a whole
lot of nothing to me
i mean nothing after a while you know
what i'm saying a [ __ ] will [ __ ]
anything man
so like you could be the baddest [ __ ]
in the world that's fine [ __ ] gonna
have you
and i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
with a 203. [ __ ] would do that
yeah happens all the time you know what
i'm saying jc had beyonce still for some
other [ __ ] how could you beat that
because he would just want some new
[ __ ] on the sky so that ain't nothing
man it's your energy it's your mind what
you bringing
to help me grow that was gonna help us
grow that what counts
preach brother preach but
i just want a bad [ __ ] that [ __ ] he's
a square he's a nobody yeah but a [ __ ]
that been said fishing his whole life
and got every girl he wanted
what is a bad [ __ ] doing for me that's
nothing
we always had that i wonder if guys like
that
are too emotionally like
damn sound bad
it doesn't seem like he would be very
successful
in relationships um just like the way
he's like talking
just the vibe i'm getting from him and i
wonder
if like guys that have slept with like
an absurd amount of women like hundreds
of girls whatever
can can are they capable of like having
a successful relationship with
where they don't cheat in their loyal
and
like they actually are happy because
i've heard that like
like i mean i think everyone knows money
can't buy happiness
and like a quality relationship what you
bringing more than just being a [ __ ]
oh it's a million bad [ __ ] walking
this earth that's the cheapest and most
easiest thing to get for [ __ ] got some
money is a [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] bam you go to like i said
you go to brazil right now it's going to
be a 10 000 bad [ __ ] you've seen your
life
you give them [ __ ] one dollar in a
coffee and that [ __ ] gonna lick your
feet man
that ain't work that's worthless to a
real [ __ ] man right you got to be a fat
slow brave regular ass [ __ ] that
finally got some money
to be imposed and i got oh i got a bad
[ __ ] like come on man
like that's a different type of breed of
human that get they rocks off to that
you know what i'm saying and i get it
y'all get your money now go
get all them [ __ ] but a [ __ ] like me
that [ __ ] is like there's nothing
you know what i mean we got our energy's
got to be connected
what i'm saying we got to grow together
that's the most important so you'll take
a basic [ __ ]
that is somebody that you want to talk
to over a bad [ __ ] that
will inspire you so you consider
yourself a bad [ __ ] no
yeah i do actually so you above
basically you don't work you have no
attributes
to the table here
i'm i inspire my men how you don't got
no job you got what's your education
listen
stop yeah no but you have to realize
that when
men make it to a certain level right
they're not checking for a woman's
education when you're when you're making
millions of dollars
you don't care about a woman's education
yes you do talk to plenty of rich men i
do i'm a rich man i got a
state of malibu okay yes
okay this is interesting because all the
red pill content
has said they don't care about a woman's
education and they don't care about
their money
let me know in the comments this is
sounding different to see the paperwork
okay we can show you paperwork go ahead
and show me the title
we gotta show a paperwork to somebody
that would make no sense
oh see she's getting defensive because
he
he was calling her out you don't even
know what it is what do you got
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] got money i get it ah negative
but when you're when
seriously there's no way you got nobody
officially when you reach a certain
level you don't care if that girl works
as a bottle girl
you don't care if this girl has a job
it don't matter i'm talking about you
personally on them you don't know me
personally
i could tell you ain't got no brain
honey i worked in corporate finance what
are you talking about
why are you not employed now because i
don't want to be so you want to be a
slave to a man with some money
i want to no honey i want to be an
inspiration for some money
how are you going inspiring please
explain that baby i just told you
obviously you weren't listening i'm
listening quite fine i see you coming in
lingerie but no
no no no no no you wasn't listening
oh my god oh my god that's so funny
um what is it like oh my gosh
i mean i have it pretty good guys like
i'm not even gonna lie my life is great
but i just wonder what it would be like
to like
just be hot and like do that for a job
that would be pretty cool and i'm gonna
lie
i'm hot that's my job i don't know where
these girls are
okay guys um let me know in the comments
if you guys agree
disagree don't forget to subscribe